je voulais trouver les mots pour vous
parler du bonheur d'avoir été adopté par
cette famille généreuse fille lumineuse
et brillante va faire [ __ ] avec elle
bon en sous prétexte que tu es un grand
artiste 12h10 mettez un dictateur tiens
égocentrique l'emmerdeur voilà
il va nous faire chier je sens il y à
une pièce climatisée
ça ne rime à rien c'est juste qu'avec
les brocantes où seule la brocante toile
et rabat vaffanculo ça me fait chier pas
il ya ton mariage
célibataire maintenant je suis je suis
veuf pas parce que ça revient au même
non pas prier mais je veux dormir au dec
malone times
m
maintenant je vous entends pas pas être
moi je me dis que j'ai bien de la chance
d'être finie si c'est un frère c'est
comme un miroir
ça fait pas de mal de temps en temps d'y
jeter un coup d'oeil
ma devise favorite oublie tout ce que tu
donnes souviens toi que tout ce que tu
reçois cet infirmier
ouais j'ai ce droit
t'inquiète pas je me dirai rien t'as
même pas mal tolérés